was macht sie machen dieses bestimmte
geräusche vom fried sind das erste was
ich esse wenn ich aus dem urlaub im
ausland zurück nach belgien komme
[Musik]
wenn man ein fest feiert ist manfred
wenn man eine neue freundin hat geht man
mit ihr pommes essen und ländern sie
nicht mehr hat geht man auch pommes
essen pommes stecken immer
[Musik]
hallo ich heiße mustafa ich heiße musik
jörg ehmer wir betreiben den imbiss
bietet der chapel ich mache das seit 32
jahren
unsere kunden essen jeden tag gute
freundin gut durchgegart außen knusprig
und innen weich das geheimnis guter pop
fried liegt in der wahl der cut-off wir
nehmen oft mit kartoffeln das sind die
besten kartoffeln und flieht zu machen
es ist eine sehr alte kartoffelsorte ich
glaube sie ist über 100 jahre alt aber
sie ist in sachen geschmack und
knusprigkeit immer noch unschlagbar
weiße wert der kfw und arbeite bereits
verkaufsmanager selbst in belgien und
wir sind ein sehr kleines land müssen
wir regionen wie flandern und die
wallonie mit unterschiedlichen größen
beliefern
in flandern sollen die pommes 11
millimeter dick sein im süden von
belgien 12 oder 13 vom free zocken 11
millimeter dick sein
das ist die richtige größe wenn sie
dünner sind werden sie schneller kalt so
sind sie viel knusprig und wenn sie zu
dick sind nehmen sie zu viel platz in
der papiertüte ein und werden dann auch
schnell kalt kinder fit ist das weiße
gold für die fritten so bleiben sie war
wenn sie heiß sind sind sie schön
knusprig wenn man sie in zu viel
pflanzenöl guard verbrennen sie sehr
schnell
[Musik]
für mich sind kaum fried die quintessenz
dessen was die belgier ausmacht etwas
ganz einfaches und doch entdecke ich
jeden tag was neues
ich heiße banale favre und bin der
vorsitzende von afri der vereinigung der
früheren betreiber man weiß nicht wer
die fritten erfunden hat aber es in die
belgier die daraus eine kunst gemacht
haben
[Musik]
die konkret werden zwei mal fertig
zuerst bei 125 grad celsius um sie vor
zu garen
beim zweiten mal erhöhen wir die
temperatur auf maximal 175 grad celsius
der schrittmacher muss viel mehr hören
als sehen ob die pommes gase der fried
macher ist wie ein orchester chef er
organisiert das chaos
die complete ein lied es geht
sie machen dieses bestimmte geräusche
[Musik]
unfried sind eine mahlzeit für sich man
kann einfach nur pommes essen vielleicht
mit ein wenig mayonnaise aber auch ohne
mayonnaise ist es eine unvergleichliche
mahlzeit
[Musik]
was man macht muss man von ganzem herzen
lieben das ist nicht ein mann macht
jeden tag das gleiche ist eingeschlossen
in einer bude und arbeitet zehn bis
zwölf stunden
die liebe zum beruf ist auch ein
geheimnis
[Musik]